Olá meus amigos minhas amigas boa noite
para mais uma live da comunidade fechada
do canal do YouTube Boa noite Rinaldo
Adriana Eliane Cristina Miriam Estela
Rinaldo e
Marta vamos discutir aqui dois artigos
interessantes em seguida vamos responder
as dúvidas de vocês
tá primeiro artigo que eu queria falar
para vocês é sobre uma tendência a gente
tem que levar em consideração que pode
ter aí um viés tá que que é viés uma
forçação de barra vamos vamos dizer
assim existe agora estudos falando sobre
alimentação à base de mico proteínas
proteínas do
Fungo isso pode ser uma situação aí que
tá sendo apresentada
para avançar a agenda do
ismo mas não um veganismo raiz mas um
veganismo impulsionado aí pelos
dominadores globais tá que podem ter
interesses escusos aí enfim mas eu
queria falar s com vocês sobre esse
artigo que é um artigo bem interessante
né então o fungo pode ser segundo esse
artigo mais eficaz do que uma dieta
vegana convencional para diminuir os
níveis de colesterol LDL então estudo
que compara uma
dieta onívora com uma dieta com mico
proteínas retiradas um fungo chamado
fusarium em relação ao controle das
lipoproteínas o colesterol LDL né então
vamos mergulhar nesse mundo da mico
proteína um tipo de proteína derivada do
Fungo fusaro venenatum parece veneno né
venenatum mas é o nome do fungo e
explorar como né Essa proteína derivada
desse fungo pode ser uma arma POD na
luta contra o colesterol então a gente
sabe por exemplo que as estatinas são
retiradas dos fungos né então existe o
fungo do
eh da levedura levedura vermelha do do
arroz vermelho levedura do arroz
vermelho que daí que foi feito todos os
outros as outras estatinas né então esse
estudo recente aponta por um declínio
impressionante no colesterol Total LDL
após o consumo diário de refeiçõ
contendo micropro e comparando a dietas
com consumo de peixe e carne então vamos
desvendar essas descobertas juntos e
entender a ciência por trás desses
estudos Então vamos entender primeiro o
que que é a Mico proteína porque que ela
é significativa no contexto da Saúde
cardiovascular ela é uma fonte de
proteína rica em fibra originada de um
processo de fermentação contínua do
fungo fusaro venenado átom então a sua
relevância vem do fato de ser associado
à redução dos níveis de colesterol LDL o
chamado ma colesterol que está ligado ao
maior risco de doenças
cardiovasculares Então nesse estudo o
foco está nas mudanças observadas nos
participantes com colesterol
alto e vamos analisar como é que a
inclusão da microtea em dietas diárias
poderia influenciar esses níveis de
colesterol e outros fatores de risco
cardiometabólico então então trata--se
de um ensaio Clínico randomizado
envolveu 72 adultos que foram estudados
por qu semanas esses 72 adultos tinham
sobrepeso obesidade e níveis elevados de
colesterol os participantes substituíram
as proteínas de carne ou peixe por mico
proteína desse fusarium em quantidades
proporcionais ao peso corporal uma dieta
que não se restringia outros alimentos
então houve um resultados
encorajadores uma redução de
11,6 MG por Dil ambos no colesterol
total e LDL
colesterol no grupo que consumiu a Mico
proteína comparado ao grupo controle que
consumiu carne ou peixe
Tá então vamos agora fazer uma
observação mais próxima dos resultados
secundários que além do colesterol Total
LDL também eles analisaram a glicose dos
sangue e o c peptídeo ou peptídeo C que
é um fragmento da insulina então quando
o peptídeo c tá mais alto isso é um
indicador de que tem resistência
insulínica tá então pid ser geralmente a
gente usa ele para ver se a pessoa está
tendo
eh uma produção muito acentuada de
insulina enquanto que o grupo que
consumiu micoe não apresentou mudanças
significativas nesses marcadores de
glicose houve um aumento no grupo
controle que consumiu carne ou peixe
então eles viram que o pessoal consumiu
carne ou peixe tinha uma glicose um
pouco mais alta de quem consumiu a Mico
proteína eo sugere que embora a Mico
proteína pareça ter pouco efeito sobre o
controle glicêmico de forma direta ela
não causa deterioração desse parâmetro
então não piora a Glicemia mas o o
resultado foi melhor do que se fosse
consumido carne ou peixe é um pouco
curioso isso né Eu contesto um pouco
esse resultado não creio que a carne ou
peixe possa
ter provocado um aumento de glicose no
grupo controle né um pouco estranho isso
daí pode ter outros fatores
confundidores que eles não levarem em
consideração então o que que pode ter
contribuído paraa redução do colesterol
LDL nesse grupo que utilizou A
micoe então eles acreditam que foi a
fibra né em especial a fibra solúvel
chamado betaglucana que tem bastante
quantidade nessa microtea são dois ter
do volume da fibra da mico proteína a
betaglucana e que isso foi o responsável
pela redução do LDL colesterol então
também o estudo observou uma diminuição
na ingestão de colesterol no grupo da
microtea Então esse pessoal também comeu
menos colesterol eentão eles acham que
isso possa ter relação também com essa
redução dos
níveis então esses estudos reforçam a
ideia de que o um tipo específico de
fibra poderia ser mais efetivo na gestão
dos níveis de colesterol do que a
quantidade total de
fibra Então qual que é a relevância
dessas descobertas né então esse estudo
sugere que trocar proteínas animais por
microtea pode ser uma estratégia
promissora para baixar o colesterol LDL
e essa alternativa pode ser mais eficaz
principalmente se a microtea substituir
a carne na dieta contudo em importante
ressaltar que ela não mostrou muitos
efeitos sobre o controle de
glicose e também não houve uma mudança
significativa no peso entre os grupos
que eram pessoas sobrepeso obesas então
não foi diferente a peso então
reforçando que essa redução de
colesterol não teve impacto na perda de
peso né então esse estudo pode ter sido
utilizado como
recurso
para avançar agenda né do veganismo não
do veganismo Raiz mas de veganismo que
tá sendo aí promovido por agendas
globalistas né para parar o consumo de
carne
né então esse estudo sugere que você
deveria explorar mais produtos
alimentícios que tem essa mico proteína
como substituto de carne as refeições né
E que poderia favorecer a saúde do
coração então eu achei interessante
estudo aqui mas a gente tem que analisar
com muita cautela Esse estudo ok E
aquela história que é mais sustentável
pro meio ambiente quer dizer Esse é o
ponto que eles usam de justificativo
para o veganismo não porque a pessoa
optou pelo veganismo porque ela não
gosta de fazer mal os animais uma
questão pessoal mas eles estão usando
isso como agenda ambiental
né para empurrar esses produtos que não
sejam carne ou frango ou peixe
né então tem um problema aí tem um viés
Esse estudo além do que eu já falei
sobre essa minha teoria do globalismo
existe um patrocínio da marl Foods tá
então tem aí um conflito de interesse
nesse estudo então é importante ficar
muito Atento e vamos ver aí os próximos
estudos que podem aparecer
eh sobre esse assunto Adriana tá
perguntando aqui não Então faz mal comer
carne todos os dias Adriano Isso é
discutível muita gente diz que não é um
problema comer carne vermelha todos os
dias eu tô imaginando você tá
perguntando sobre carne vermelha e não
carnes em geral né Eu recomendo que se
coma carne vermelha duas a três vezes
semana e os outros dias você tem de
comer carne branca mas is é mais uma
precaução porque a gente não tem dados
definitivos para dizer que a carne
vermelha realmente faz mal pelo menos do
meu ponto de vista
tá bem o
próximo artigo aqui
é uma comparação interessante que
fizeram entre vários tipos de açúcares
Tá então vamos analisar os efeitos que o
açúcar pode ter negativo pra saúde é um
estudo controlado com adultos jovens em
que o consumo diário de bebidas adoçadas
com açúcar
eh teve impactos diferentes de acordo
com o tipo de Açúcar o impacto foi
diferente em relação ao tipo de
sensibilidade a insulina vou explicar
mais a
respeito então Esse estudo
averiguemos se você ingeriu Glicose
sacarose que é a junção de frutose com
glicos né é um de sacarídeo que é o
açúcar comum de mesa né sacarose
americano chama de
sucrose então comparou sacarose que é o
açúcar de mesa glicose xarope de milho
de alta frutose Então esse é o pior de
todos tá então muita gente pensa que é
tudo igual não é tudo igual você vai ver
que tem diferenças importantes aí em
relação ao que o organismo faz com cada
tipo de Açúcar o tipo de resistência
insulina que vai
acontecer
então a sensibilidade a insulina é um
indicador muito importante que a gente
usa no dia dia clínico é bem importante
paraa saúde metabólica Quando Você
consome alimentos e bebidas ricas em
açúcar o corpo precisa processar colocar
essa glicose para dentro da célula e o
excesso que não é utilizado ele tem que
transformar em outra forma de
armazenamento ou glicogênio ou pode
virar gordura através da lipogênese
e a insulina ajuda nesse processamento
tanto para jogar para dentro da célula
quanto para processar o excesso desse
carboidrato desse
açúcar nós sabemos ISO todos nós estamos
sabendo de cor né careca de saber que o
consumo excessivo e prolongado de Açúcar
vai sobrecarregar seu organismo levar a
pré-diabetes e levar a inflamação
crônica e várias
doenças Então esse estudo em questão
considerou vários índices de avaliação
da sensibilidade de insulina o principal
deles é o hom
r e foram analisados 131 adultos jovens
saudáveis participaram desse ensaio
controlado que durou 20 dias e houve
então grupos diferentes um grupo bebeu
bebidas adoss adas com E essas bidas
adoss adas eh tinham o equivalente a 25%
da ingestão energética diária Então o
que variava é o tipo de Açúcar que era
utilizado então foram feitas a
avaliações como Glicemia de jejum e
pós-prandial e os níveis de insulina
foram feitos foram aferidos antes e após
o período de consumo dessas
bebidas então o peso corporal entre os
grupos não diferiu no final do estudo
mas outros resultados foram bem
diferentes enquanto que o grupo que
consumiu glicose como
ah 25% da caloria por dia né como
expliquei através de bebidas mostrou uma
diminuição nos de glicose em
jejum o que consumiu glicose aqueles que
consumiram frutose tiveram uma pior
índice de sensibilidade insulina no
fígado então o fígado foi sobrecarregado
com essa frutose doope de
milho Então qual que é o tipo de
alimento que tem bastante arop de de
alta frutose são essas bebidas adoçadas
com esse produto por exemplo
refrigerantes
Então quando você consome um
refrigerante com esse tipo de de xarope
de milho de alta frutose você tá
sobrecarregando o seu
fígado então sabemos que a resistência a
insulina é um fenômeno complexo
alarmante que aumenta o risco de
desenvolvimento de várias doenças
inclusive o próprio pré-diabetes
diabetes então é muito importante
entender como que a insulina responde a
cada um desses açúcares para desvendar
os efeitos deletérios na saúde
metabólica então níveis pós prandis ou
seja pós alimentação de glicose insulina
como avaliados pelo teste de tolerância
oral glicose refletem principalmente a
sensibilidade a insulina no músculo você
tem indicadores aí diferentes que são
usados para avaliar a sensibilidade
muscular a
insulina e por outro lado você tem o o í
ome que foca na sensibilidade hepática e
insulina Então são marcadores diferentes
o marcador que vê a sensibilidade do
músculo chama índice stvol tá que eu nem
conheço é uma coisa que eu não conhecia
conhecia com esse estudo aqui então o
estudo observou que o consumo de glicose
impactou negativamente a sensibilidade a
insulina no
músculo enquanto índices hepáticos foram
mais afetados pelo consumo de frit então
a
frutose do xarope de milho impactou mais
o fígado e a glicose impactou mais o
músculo essas diferenças podem ser
atribuídas às vias metabólicas
diferentes pelas quais a glicose e a
frutose São
processadas Então a maneira como esses
diferentes açúcares são metabolizados
pelo corpo pode ter efeitos diversos
significativos na saúde
metabólica enquanto a glicos é regulado
pelas necessidades energéticas do fígado
e geralmente processada pelos músculos
quando o fígado está cheio de glicogênio
a frutose vai diretamente pro fígado
onde seu processamento é praticamente
incontrolado levando a lipogênese
formação de gordura no fígado então o
choral de Mir de alta frutose é um
grande vilão da esteatose ou gordura
exagerada cerca de 85% da frutose
ingerida estada pelo fígado altas taxas
de lipogênese Ou seja a formação de
gordura contribui pro acúmulo de gordura
nesse órgão e também nos outros órgãos
em volta aumenta o risco de resistência
insulina mesmo sem ganho de peso então
estudos também mostraram que o consumo
elevado de frutose pode levar essa maior
formação de gordura quando comparado ao
consumo de glicose ou carboidratos
complexos por exemplo a ingestão de
frutose em um contexto de dieta
equilibrada em peso ainda mostrou
aumento de lipogênese e gura no fígado
mesmo que a pessoa não tenha aumentado
de peso destacando o perigo que são as
bebidas adoçadas e os alimentos
industrializados que t esse produto né
para a nossa
saúde Então os resultados desse estudo
sugere que os efeitos nocivos do consumo
de bebidas açucaradas especialmente com
frutose estão ligados a vários fatores
de risco
cardiometabólicos independentemente das
mudanças de peso corporal pessoa pode
continuar um peso bom mas tá cheio de
gordura visceral por causa da frutose do
Milho Então deve ser evitadas a todo
custo certo
pessoal então é isso vamos às perguntas
ao
vivo Vamos abrir aqui o o arquivo das
perguntas pergunta aqui do Reinaldo
sobre probiótico estou tomando
antibiótico já tomo probiótico uma vez
ao dia Preciso aumentar a dose de
probiótico pois vou tomar antibiótico
por mais 10
dias que eu sugiro que você faça
Reinaldo é você interromper
temporariamente o uso de probiótico até
você terminar o antibiótico tá E aí você
pode até aumentar a dose temporariamente
do probiótico eu acho que não vale a
pena associar os dois porque você tá
meio que jogando dinheiro fora
tá porque o antibiótico ele vai meio que
anular o
probiótico Adriana tá perguntando sobre
o artigo e os adoçantes T ação na
insulina também Adriana os adoçantes
acabam tendo uma ação indireta porque
ele estimulam através assim do gosto
doce da
boca o glp1 que tá lá no intestino
delgado então eles apesar de não ter
caloria eles acabam provocando uma
liberação insulina por conta do Sabor
doce da boca Ok Deu para entender a
explicação
Adriana próxima
pergunta diago ateromatose da horta se o
pass se a pessoa não é obesa é ativa com
os níveis de colesterol normal todos os
exames nor mais sangue não fumante não
diabético alimentação saudável o que
mais poderia ser um fator para
desenvolver idade fumo
né genética também pode
interferir ou existe algo a mais que a
medicina tradicional não
considera tem que ver se a pessoa foi
exposta a metal pesado pode aumentar a
aterosclerose tem que ver se essa pessoa
não tem um estresse oxidativo exagerado
por algum motivo tem que ver se aa
pessoa não tá exposta a poluente
orgânico persistente a toxina de fungo
tá tudo isso pode interferir e e
acelerar a ateromatose metal pesado é
mais comum
tá isso geralmente não é investigado
pelos médicos da Medicina mais Ortodoxa
Então vale a pena pesquisar metal
pesado intoxicações aí por toxinas em
geral e se a pessoa não fuma também O
fumo é uma coisa que acelera a traumat
tá no tratamento de infecção fúngica
tapioca seria uma opção aceitável de
carboidrato
depende depende muito se você engerir
tapioca com gordura e proteína e a
pessoa não tiver assim uma resistência
insulínica muito alta pode até ser
aceitável
sim
Ok qual a posologia do coliro bright Ice
3 você pode pingar umas duas gotas em
cada olho a cada 4 horas tá quanto tempo
deve ser utilizado pelo menos 6 meses
viu
Rita Isaac a micose tratada apenas com
pumada na unha ou é necessário algum
medicamento complementar muita gente
muitos médicos passam o Fluconazol de
150 MG semanal tá Fluconazol 150 MG uma
vez por semana e muitas vezes você tem
que utilizar por muitas semanas utilizar
por 10 12 semanas Ok Esse é o tramento
ortodoxo tá eu tenho vídeos no meu canal
o sobre uso de óleo essencial de
melaleuca de orégano tá para tratamento
de micose de unha pode dar uma checada
depis no
canal Maria Helena é muito polêmico com
aço colágeno do pé de galinha de granjas
dizem ser muito fraquinho por bater
essas aves com 45 dias pode trazer
pesquisa sobre isso ou uma live dentro
do seu conhecimento conseguiremos saber
uma verdade mais fiel obrigado eu vou
colocar esse assunto aqui na nossa pauta
tá exame gente Eu Não Posso avaliar
exame tá
eh isso aqui não posso fazer tá o que eu
posso dizer que o zinco ideal é que
esteja em torno de 100 e também o cobre
em torno de 100
tá essa deveria ter sido minha pergunta
semana passada no grupo do Facebook
modulação hormonal bioidêntica todos vão
em médicos da integrativa e nos
comentários dizem que os médicos falam
mulher sem útero melhor usar a
progesterona
transdérmica não usar Utrogestan vaginal
oral
lá tem mulheres de todas as idades é
muito comum meninas novas já sem útero e
com dúvidas sobre por causa de médicos
pensar diferente você pode me explicar
isso por
favor eu não concordo tá o que os
ginecologistas comuns dizem que mulher
sem útero não precisa de progesterona e
não é verdade porque a progesterona é
importante pros ossos e pro cérebro
também agora não usar oral porque a
mulher não tem útero desconheço essa
informação
tá vou até dar uma checada
aqui mas eu tô achando um tanto quanto
estranho Talvez seja uma confusão isso
daí
me dê um minutinho que eu tô dando uma
checada aqui
não achei nada sobre isso tá eu acho que
tá tendo uma confusão em relação a usar
ou não progesterona em mulher com útero
ou sem útero eu não conheço essa
informação que não pode usar vi oral em
mulheres sem útero ok Não concordo com
isso e não e não entenderia
por essa alegação
tá Marilda vantagem ou desvantagem de
tomar otato de magnésio ao invés de
outros tipos de
magnésio eu não tenho muita experiência
com orotato de magnésio tá o a vantagem
teórica seria o ácido orótico que é uma
das substânci que temão no ciclo de
crebs tá que é o principal ciclo
formador de energia fora da questão ali
da da cascata mitocondrial que acontece
na membrana interna tá então o que
acontece
eh orótico é igual mais ou menos o ácido
málico ele tá lá dentro do ciclo de
crepes quando eu fiz o vídeo sobre 10
tipos de magnésio Eu acho que eu toquei
no assunto
do do orotato de magnésio mas eu não tô
lembrado agora porque tem muito tempo
que eu fiz esse
vídeo Você chegou a ver o meu vídeo
sobre os 10 tipos de magnésio ser é bom
você dar uma
olhada eu vou chocar também uma outra
fonte
[Música]
aqui eu acho que esse orotato magnésio
não é muito diferente de você tomar
dimalato ou usar o o que é o que tem o
ácido málico né
tá então ise seria mais ou menos
equivalente ao de
malato o senhor recomenda a vacinação A
cada 10 anos da vacina antitetânica
paraa população em geral crianças jovens
e idosos sim recomendo BL Anderson acho
que antitetânica é
segura me relembre por favor Quais são
os suplementos indicados para expulsar
ou atenuar os efeitos da proteína Spike
tá enac Nato kinase
eh o extrato de dente de leão esses
esses três são os principais tá e eu
falo mais sobre isso num vídeo que tá no
Rumble eu sei que o Rumble no Brasil
hoje tá bloqueado mas se você usar uma
VPN você consegue entrar lá e acessar o
vídeo que eu falo disso daí lá no Rumble
Porque eu tive que tirar esse vídeo lá
do do
YouTube mas é basicamente o mais
importantes é nac Nat kinasi e o dente
de leão Tá mas tem
outros cidade de potássio 200 migros uma
vez ao dia eficaz para câimbras Depende
se for a câimbra for por falta de
potássio sim se for por falta de
magnésio não vai fazer muita
diferença
eh na Live anterior eu falei que hubina
glicada deveria ser até 5 e me o que
equivale a 111 glicose no sangue ess
esse 111 é a média é a média de glicose
tá não é glicose de jejum você tá
confundido a média de glicose com
glicose de jejum Tá bom então espero que
você tenha entendido mas se você tiver
aí na Live eu esclareço mais
tá Eliseu tá falando que tapioca não é
açúcar refinado Com certeza não é é ele
é um
carboidrato que não é o melhor
carboidrato não vai chegar a ser um o
carboidrato super complexo mas se você
ingerir el junto com gordura e proteína
você vai reduzir bastante a absorção do
da Tapioca e não é para mim eu não acho
melhor tá longe ser o melhor
carbohidrato
elu
tá eu tenho duas perguntas o azul de
metileno interfere nos
probióticos Que eu saiba
não não conheço estudo que faz a
respeito também gostaria de perguntar se
não se pode tomar vitaminas por conta
própria porque há incentivo dos médicos
Eu não entendi a
pergunta Pode tomar Vitamina por conta
própria com tanto você sabe que você tá
fazendo Tá é isso tá perguntando Doutor
Qual é adoçante usado no vinho tinto
suave adoçante do vinho tinto que eu sab
eles não colocam adoçante em vinho não
só se for um vinho muito nem precisaria
porque tem tem um açúcar natural da Uva
né Adriana vejo os médicos promovendo
marcas porque os polivitamínicos não
fazem diferença na
saúde ao menos é o que eu vi em alguns
vídeos Andre Desculpa eu não tô
entendendo bem o que você tá querendo
dizer
não tá um pouco P confuso vamos paraa
próxima pergunta aqui do
questionário a
fórmula
n vezes 8 é correta para se calcular
glicose no sangue miligram por decilitro
quando temos apenas o valor da
hemoglobina
glicada Isso é uma estimativa da glicose
média tá é só uma estimativa não é o que
eh não é igual você medir a glicose no
sangue tá
Qual que é o valor de glicose no sangue
considerado diabetes tipo 2 acima de 120
tá em
jejum ou até de 100 90 até 1220 seria
algum grau de resistência insulínica uso
que cetina 750 MG por dia é eficaz para
alergias sim em geral a picadas de
inseto vai depender de cada paciente mas
geralmente cai sim
Marildo Qual que é a diferença entre a
gluc ventage e beberina esse gluc
ventage eu fiquei sabendo dele
recentemente tá é uma fma de
beberina que de na
manipulação que é de alta absorção
tá vou até conferir isso porque foi que
a farmacêutica me falou me dá só um
minuto aqui
tá então uma beberina de alta absorção
então Teoricamente é uma beberina melhor
do que a beberina comum
tá é mais B disponível cinco vezes mais
B
disponível
akm funciona como em
pique tem algum efeito colateral
não não vai ser tão potente quanto o os
pic né vai estimular o glp1 através do
uso do da bactéria kirm mocin
fila tá mas não é tão potente quanto o
Epic não tá só é mais suave mais natural
porque é uma fibra tá que é tirado uma
planta e isso estimula o crescimento da
qum mifil
Tá mas não é tão potente quanto o Zique
não
infelizmente efeito colateral não sei te
dizer eu nunca usei esse produto ainda
[Música]
não vou ficar te devendo essa
resposta Quais são os melhores
suprimentos para ajudar na insônia pós
menopausa o principal seria a
progesterona base micronizada bioral que
vai aumentar o alo pregnenolona que tem
ação gaba gabaérgica Então vai melhorar
a insônia principal Mas você pode usar
taurina você pode usar você pode usar
teanina você pode usar melatonina você
pode usar inclusive estrato de
ervas que ajudam no sono né que é o PR
slep então tem uma série de recursos
aí o Adon maltitol seguro e ele é um dos
polióis tá que é um tipo de álcool ele
acaba dando disbiose tá se usar de vez
em quando não tem problema mas eu não
recomendo o uso diário dele não todos
esses que termina em All são um pouco
problemáticos porque eles dão
disbiose Qual o valor ótimo de ferritina
para homens
ah por volta de 100 tá Pedro por volta
de
Eliane uso o T3 e T4 pela manhã e posso
ficar e apó de tomar fico 30 minutos em
jejum no período da tarde tomo T3
gostaria de saber se no período da tarde
também é necessário sim tem que ter
jejum em qualquer horário então se você
for tomar à tarde toma meia hora antes
do almoço ou Du horas
depois para herpes como tomar lisina Se
for para prevenção 500 mg por dia se for
para tratamento por volta de 1 g por dia
tem horário não não tem horário você
pode tomar 500 mg duas vezes ao dia de
manhã e de noite mas não tem horário não
tá não precisa tomar com alimentação
na na Live passada perguntei como é que
a pessoa que tá no banheiro com
constipação pode fazer para evacuar
imediatamente Quando você diz que o óleo
de coco faz essa pessoa evacuar em
alguns minutos Esse óleo de coco não são
vários minutos tá esse óleo de coco
precisa estar acompanhado de água quente
ou apenas óleo de coco eh OC sozinho é
suficiente mas não vai ser rápido não
vai demorar muitos minutos tá
não Eu já respondi semana passada O
Eliseu é é o uso do do enema tá tem que
fazer enema para ser
imediato os efeitos da beberina são
imediatos o que você quer dizer com
imediato Não entendi bem isso porque
assim você vai o efeito da beberina vai
demorar uns dias para fazer efeito agora
não sei o que você tá querendo dizer com
imediato
né ela reduz o pico de Açúcar dos
alimentos no organismo reduz
Qual é o risco de o mioma se o mioma
crescer muito mesmo se ele não causando
dor ele pode causar sangramento não é só
dor ele pode causar sangramento e a
pessoa fic anêmica por conta do mioma tá
esse é é um efeito muito comum do mioma
não é só dor não tá a única solução é
cirurgia não você pode estar usando
substâncias antiinflamatórias e iodo
para inibir o crescimento do
bioma jovem com menos de 30 anos caindo
o cabelo levemente o que pode ser jovem
de que sexo homem ou
mulher se for homem provavelmente é uma
a Lope androgenética
precoce Se for mulher provavelmente ela
é um eflúvio telógeno por estresse
tá numa Live recente por causa de uma
pergunta feita pelo Carlos você
descobriu que o azum mitil pode
antagonizar os efeitos do óxido nítrico
e essa Vas dilatação pode ser anulada
usando alimentos hicos e
Nitrato praticando exercícios físicos
regularmente e mantendo boa hidratação
você comentou que queria olhar isso com
mais calma não eu olhei na durante a
Live mesmo tá eu eu acho que uma boa
solução é Tom horário diferente porque
eu faço uso tanto de azul de metileno
quanto de substâncias que promovem O
óxido lío
tá eu faço uso das duas coisas ao mesmo
tempo pode começar logo com suplemento
probiótico 100 bilhões por dia a pessoa
tem que ingerir de 25 bilhões no
primeiro mês probiótico de 50 bilhões no
segundo mês e de 100 bilhões no terceiro
mês vai depender muito da pessoa em si
tá tem gente que não bem com probiótico
que vai dar gases Então tem que ser
individual isso daí
tá eu começaria com uma dose mais baixa
para
testar o que poderia causar variações de
pressão arterial em repouso com picos
seguidos de baixo em paciente saudável
com níveis bons exames Gerais sem pla
arterosclerose mas comão bêntica após
menopausa tanta coisa pode causar
isso pode ser Estresse pode
ser mais comum ser é causar variação de
pressão
arterial poderia se relacionar com
eventuais disfunções de adrenal e
tireoides sim mas são disfunções
secundárias geralmente ao estresse
tá é possível reverter os efeitos da
picada e da proteí Spike ou o senhor
acha que não há estudos suficientes eu
acho que não há estudos suficientes
Antônio certeza ninguém tem
hein eu disse que as picadas antigas são
seguras Mas será que os grupos maticos
também não colocaram Spike secretamente
é uma possibilidade eu diria remota mas
existe como é que eu posso ter certeza
não tem como ter certeza não tem como
ter certeza Antônio
e realmente você tá colocando aí uma
dúvida pertinente eu acho improvável até
remoto mas não acho impossível ou
não você eu já ouvi falar do trabalho do
professor lá de Carvalho Sim
conheço concorda com a visão dele sobre
geopolítica sabe é o Olávio de Carvalho
é é um nome assim como o nome do
bolsonaro que divide muitas pessoas tá
eu prefiro não entrar em política aqui
esse grupo não é de
política é um grupo sobre saúde tá de
repente se eu falo bem ou se eu falo mal
eu vou afastar pessoas aqui do grupo e
Não é esse o objetivo nosso
tá vamos às perguntas ao
vivo Então essa história do pé de frango
tá eh eu o colágeno do boi é mais é mais
eficiente tá faz caldo de ossos Você
pode até fazer caldo de ossos de boi e
caldo de ossos de galinha tá mas eu acho
que o caldo de ossos de boi é mais
eficiente para isso do que ficar comendo
P pé de frango
tá é tem vários Poli ou multivitamínicos
que tem
pouquíssimo eh vitamina sim
especialmente no Brasil que a legislação
não deixa subir a
dose por que que não se pode tomar
vitaminas por conta própria porque os
polivitaminas T pouca ação boa Adriana
agora entendi né Se o pessoal Diz Que
vitamina não serve para nada por que que
eles dizem para não tomar por conta
própria é realmente é um
pouco contestador isso daí
né eu te diria que o que eles alegam é
que as vitaminas não fariam bem e
poderiam até fazer mal esse que
indicativo que esse pessoal
usa pessoa com anemia hemolítica pode
tomar
lugol poderia mas eu não recomendo o uso
de lugol sem acompanhamento médico tá o
que não pode fazer queem tem anemia
hemolítica é tomar o usar o ozônio ou
usar vitamina C em altas doses tá
terapias oxidativas em geral
não o Eliseu tem vários óleo de coco
você pode usar magnésio para para esse
efeito
tá de nada
eass
ã então Eh se você for usar o a
macrodantina por poucas semanas pouc
poucos dias você suspende o probiótico
temporariamente e depois você volta A
probiótico tá depois que acabar o
antibiótico própolis Verde orgânico pode
estar em forma de tintura
cólica então essa comparação aqui não tá
fazendo muito sentido
tá você pode colocar um própolis Verde
orgânico em solução alcoólica ou não
então não sei não tô entendendo essa
comparação que você tá me pedindo para
fazer aqui
eh mais concentrado seria melhor
tá ok vanet tem alguma
dúvida seja bem-vinda ou ou seja
bem-vindo Desculpa eu não sei se é homem
ou mulher
temos mais dúvidas Pessoal pessoal que
deixou pergunta no documento tá ao vivo
vocês querem que eu esclareça algum
ponto que talvez não tenha ficado Claro
das respostas do
documento Sim várias Então faça suas
perguntas porque já estamos com 40 e
poucos minutos de Live tá
Não não é dois tipo não é bem assim não
viu
Eliseu Não é bem assim
não Quantos ml deur de camomila tomar
antes dormir vai depender da
concentração da
tintura seria melhor ser injeção ou por
via oral você quer dizer isso depende da
do grau de anemia se for uma anemia
muito acentuada
faa injetável
tá então uma hora te domes
eu então o Evanete
[Música]
ah a Interpretação da Medicina Ortodoxa
que faz mal porque a gordura saturada
mas eu não concordo e muitos médicos não
concordam com isso tá então por exemplo
a gente
usa a banha de porco para fritura e o
pessoal da Medicina Ortodoxa não
recomenda pode ser usado continuamente a
tintura de camomila
gente eu vou ficar mais 5 minutos tá e
vou sair com 50 minutos de
Live Omega
omega3 reduz placa de ateroma
eh isoladamente não pode prevenir mas
não vai desfazer a placa não
antiinflamatório fica muito tempo no
corpo ou é eliminado
rápido é eliminado não tão rápido mas
ele não fica anos no corpo não
tá desconheço essa informação
Eliseu Eu que agradeço Adriana
sim pode consumir junto não vejo
problema
nenhum esses são boas opções Eliseu
tá não não diria que uma melhor que a
outra você tem que ver qual que você se
adapta
melhor não existe essa equivalência
Eliseu porque homens e mulheres são
diferentes tá grosseiramente falando eu
diria que seria 100 a 150 Mas isso não é
uma coisa que faz muito sentido fazer
essa
comparação é a mesma
coisa Eu Fico muito agradecido pela sua
gratidão
viu abacate em geral Pode liberar
estamina assim
tá não acetina não elimina a estamina
ela tem efeito antistamínico mas ela não
elimina
estamina sim a maioria dos
antiinflamatórios têm danos aos rins ao
fígado e alguns dão danos ao coração tá
e ao estômago também
né tô falando aatos comuns tá de
farmácia tá tipo de clofenac mesulid
buprofeno
não conheço esse alimento que elimina a
estamina
tá eu acredito que o á lático aí seja só
um estabilizante do produto tá o
Eliseu não não tem nada a ver o
bloqueador de luz azul ele vai evitar
que a luz que você vai ver durante a
noite vai te causar problemas de saúde
não é a mesma coisa que ficar no escuro
Du horas
não não al não é a mesma coisa
não sim isso acontece
Sim Sim esse é é o conceito do li
Gut proteínas mal digeridas que entram
na corrente sanguínea causando autta
imunidade
de nada
Evanete mais um minuto eu vou
sair Tem um vídeo sobre isso no canal
Eliseu só lá assistir
Tá sim a glicina ajuda a induzir O sono
tá glina é interessante para calar o
cérebro também
eu não tô lembrado desse Card não Eliseu
Porque alguns dos meus materiais eu
tenho uma gerente de mídias que me ajuda
tá então eu não vou saber te responder
isso agora
aqui não sei te dizer se prolongo sono
ru ter que pesquisar
isso bem pessoal Muito obrigado pela
participação de vocês e pelas suas
perguntas o nível das perguntas tá cada
vez mais alto agradeço vocês a estarem
me incentivando a estudar cada vez mais
e nos nos vemos na próxima semana um
grande abraço para
vocês tchau tchau tchau tchau